henri-françois de breteuil bonjour et
merci de nous recevoir dans votre
château alors là on est dans la salle à
manger décorée
c'est un grand plaisir d'avoir de vous
accueillir ici et nous sommes en effet
dans la salle mais la grande salle à
manger du château où plusieurs scènes
historiques ont eu lieu notamment le
lancement de l'entente cordiale dans les
années 1900 mais pour ces fêtes de noël
en parler oui et pour veut l'entendre
voilà pour ces faits de noël et du
nouvel an nous avons d'en consacrer
cette salle à manger au mariage de peau
d'âne avec ses tables décorées
on imagine que tous les personnages des
contes de perrault bien vite le château
il parle vont venir honorer peau d'âne
et le prince qui vont se marier la nuit
de noël château de conte de fées on
pourrait dire ça tombe retail le château
de breteuil ses châteaux des contes de
perrault
oui parce qu'il ya une raison historique
à cela c'est que charles perrault a
travaillé pour une mise en scène qui
était ministre du des finances du roi
louis xiv
charles perrault étant directeur du
trésor aux arts donc il est assez
logique là où de rendre hommage à l'
apéro qui a écrit tardivement après sa
carrière de haut fonctionnaire en
quelque sorte les fameux conte de
perrault au début du 18e en 1703 pour
être précis alors vous parlez de vos
ancêtres ministre de louis xiv
le château et dans votre famille depuis
qu'on peut dater sa wii le château est
dans la famille depuis sa construction
c'est sûr depuis 1610 en ligne directe
depuis 10 712 en ligne directe en ligne
directe depuis 10,712 mais l'homme qui
l'a fait construire thibault des portes
chancelier d'henri iv était un grand
nombre des bretons est en ligne directe
depuis 17h12 justement depuis un un
ministre de louis xiv puis un ministre
de louis 15 et ses deux parents fils
quoi de père en fils depuis 17 ans en
lignée directe c'est ça doit te rise un
récipient c'est assez rarissime que le
château qui a le nom d'une famille
appartiennent toujours à la même famille
depuis trois siècles jeu ça fait trois
siècles exactement cette année alors
évidemment dans votre famille
10e et 2014 beaucoup de ministres sous
l'ancien régime naturellement et puis et
puis on parlait tout à l'heure des
années des négociations qui sont passés
ici même ça c'était votre arrière grand
père votre compte non c'était mon grand
père henry qui était le huitième marquis
de breteil enrayer bourret et only de
bretagne le tonnelier vaisselle non pas
trop nui tonnelier 8e boitillant reid
bretelles tout court et qui a été un ami
très proche du prince de galles futur
edouard cinq ans fait et c'est lui qui
était un bon vivant comme chacun sait et
cetera qui aimait paris les femmes la
bonne chère et serra et c'est mon grand
père qui a réuni pour la première fois
le futur edouard 7 prince de galles l
époque et gambetta et cette scène et de
1881 et elle est considérée comme le
lancement de l'entente cordiale et en
1904 quelques jours après après la
signature de ce traité
edward said des jeunes dans cette salle
à manger comme il a souvent fait avec
mon grand-père et des personnages connus
comme la comtesse greffulhe qui la
duchesse de guermantes de proust est là
et d'autre on en vit un riz puisque vous
parlez de 2,2 pouces ce groupe était
aussi on le retourne dans proust enfin
il a été un des personnages dos et donc
ces bruits riposta proulx stade louis ii
lui a donné à ab-so-lu-ment très
transparent est ce qu'il appelle
hannibal debré au thb égal henri de
breteuil et il parle des promenades que
swan faisait avec bréauté il parle aussi
du château ils changent un peu le nom il
appelle bréauté ou buzz
il de temps en temps bretteville mais on
semble proust est venu ici et il est
tout à fait légitime que nous l'ayons
installé dans la plus belle chambre
d'hommes du château qui est la chambre
de lacq
il est venu on sait que proust est venu
on n'a pas de date précise mais on sait
qu'il est venu parce que dans les récits
qu'il fait justement il part des venue
d'edouard 7 ici il parle de certains
objets du château il parle du parc dont
qu'il a il ne peut pas ne pas être venu
mais pour être honnête on n'a pas la
date précise de sa venue
alors il ya le journal de notre grand
père vous avez alors pas découvert parce
que vous le connaissiez
oui enfin là on l'a presque découvert
parce que ce journal était très secret
puisqu'ils étaient fermés dans des
cahiers une reliés par des fermoirs en
argent tout ça était fermée à clé parce
que à mon avis mon grand père qui disait
des choses un peu secrète sur la vidéo
sur la politique certes mais aussi sur
la vie de ses contemporains 8e des rues
il tenait pas trop à ce que ça se sache
et c'est vrai que j'ai retrouvé un jour
dans les archives et qu'on a qu'on a eue
de ce journal global qui fait peut-être
trois quatre mille pages dont on a
extrait les parties les plus importantes
pour une publication il ya deux ans et
ça m'a toujours intéressée de retrouver
les manuscrits des ancêtres écrit comme
ça sur le vif et on a plusieurs ancêtres
d'ailleurs henri sa femme constance de
castelbaljac également louis-nicolas de
breteil qui était introducteur des
ambassadeurs de louis xiv
donc c'est une manière et puis on a
aussi publié les extraits de proust bien
sûr sur bréauté on est bien trouver les
liens entre la littérature et la famille
qu'est ce que ça vous a appris au fond
un séjour d'où ces lettres que vous avez
vous avez retrouvé sur votre famille que
vous ne saviez pas on ça prend ça prend
beaucoup de choses par exemple sur henry
de breteuil on voit qu'il a des
relations eu très très proche avec le
prétendant au trône de france de
l'époque et le comte de paris dont il le
trouve d'ailleurs qu'il est assez
indécis il dit les il est comme un
cheval il faut le mener très ferme parce
qu'on sait jamais s'il va aller à droite
ou à gauche
si vous voulez fait des allusions
peut-être les pertes actuelles sur
certains hommes politiques
non c'est vrai il faut dire de retourner
dans une période
bon alors le retour de la monarchie
terrible encore un peu envisageable d'un
tout petit peu après dix ans mais il y
avait encore été voté avec des député
royaliste et ses enfants il ya ça et
puis surtout il raconte beaucoup de
choses à l'occasion d'un mariage ou à
l'occasion de gens qu'il reçoit ici il
va raconter toutes les histoires de
famille alors on n'a pas tous publiés
passe quelque chose quand même qui était
en discrète qui pouvait nous amener non
pas des procès mais ne pas être reçu
dans certains endroits ce qui est
toujours désagréable mais on a publié
quand même les choses les plus
importantes et il fait des portraits
merveilleux de la famille rothschild de
la famille justement greffulhe qu'ils
ont les grands amis de ce couple et
c'est donc et puis ça prend surtout
l'homme on voit que cet homme qui
revient de la chambre des députés
peut-être à 2 heures du matin il écrit
sans la moindre ratures pour raconter à
sa femme qui est souffrant et l'époque
qui va mourir très jeunes de la
tuberculose lui racontais tout ce qui se
passe dans la politique au parlement
l'amitié avec gambetta les critiques
entre clemenceau qui n'aime pas beaucoup
qu'il respecte qui n'aime pas beaucoup
le font c'est un monarchiste très très
ouvert
finalement il veut la réconciliation
entre la république et la monarchie et
surtout il veut une politique extérieure
qui soit bonne pour sauver le pays et
dit qu'il n'y a qu'une politique
extérieure ya pas celle des monarchistes
et celle des républicains est-ce que
voilà le fait de descendre permis de
savoir de commettre saison simple ça
vous donne une responsabilité
particulière
alors il ya la responsabilité vous avez
de faire vivre d'abord son château qui
est que la demeure de vos ancêtres et
22h mai mais au-delà de ça je crois que
l'idée que que j'ai en ayant la maison
et puis derrière moi l'histoire de la
famille c'est que c'est une manière de
mettre en scène les personnages de la
famille de l'est de les rendre je dirais
de leur rendre leur légitimité de leur
rendre
la vie finalement puisqu'on les a en
personnage de cire
mais on a aussi tout leur souvenir d'une
manière de rendre toute cette époque
toutes ces époques très vivante avec les
scènes historiques
c'est pas une question de responsabilité
c'est une question peut-être de dire
qu'on va faire en sorte que le visiteur
va revivre des scènes de l'histoire est
importante et du coup il ne faut pas
qu'on oublie qu'il y avait un breteuil
dans des scènes très important de
l'histoire de france
ce qui fait que les visiteurs se disant
là il s'est passé plein de choses de
lier le plein de pages de l'histoire de
france se sont passées ici est de ce
fait le château prend de l'importance et
les ans est on va aller les révéler
encore plus au public d'une manière
aussi de les mettre en scène et un jeudi
quel point je suis un montreur dans
celle d'autres des montreurs d'ours ou
si vous voulez vraiment mais c'est vrai
que c'est important aussi de savoir d'où
on vient enfin c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose parfois qu'on oublie un
petit peu aujourd'hui je crois que la
généalogie est quelque chose qui
passionne les gens moi j'ai la chance
que les travaux s'étaient fait avant moi
quand je dis d'où on vient où il ya les
familles mais au fait il ya une histoire
oui mais c'était très important de dire
de se dire tiens ça c'est mon arrière
grand tante il emilie du châtelet arrêt
minute bretelle qui a très bien connu
voltaire de pénétrer dans son oeuvre
littéraire etc
non c'est dans ce sens que j'ai les
entend plus de savoir qu'on descende un
breton qui était peut-être compagnon de
guilaume guillaume le conquérant etc
mais savoir que ces gens ont vécu
d'abord dans une vie quotidienne dans ce
château parce qu'on aimait beaucoup la
vie quotidienne d'autrefois mais aussi
qu'ils ont une vie ou d'homme d'état ou
une vie scientifique ou une vie
littéraire importante
donc ça nous relient on se sent relié à
eux en osant alors vous avez ouvert ce
château au public il ya une quarantaine
d'années avec un certain nombre de
manifestations
au départ c'est quoi c'est une nécessité
financière
je crois qu'il ya les 2 ou celle de l'
envie de montrer je crois que la
première idée c'est que j'aime beaucoup
montré les choses au public partagé avec
le public donc le public nous apprend
beaucoup de choses
ils vont nous dire telle arme dans le
vestibule
déjà une de ce genre c'est qu'elles
viennent et le pays etc on apprend
beaucoup avec le public et puis on est
heureux de faire partager aux autres ce
que l'on a ici ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième fois bien sûr c'est qu'il
faut ouvrir les grilles à tout le monde
est très largement nous sommes ouverts
tous les jours car sinon les grilles
vont vous tomber dessus
et quand je suis arrivé dans ce château
il est il avait était inhabitée pendant
depuis la guerre pendant une trentaine
d'années et le choix était évident il
fallait l'ouvrir pour le sauver pour
faire en sorte que le château gagne sa
vie
ou alors il fallait renoncer et c'est
devenu des ruines donc là c'était mais
je crois que la motivation profonde cgem
accueillir les visiteurs
j'aime leur parler j'aime les tous les
samedis dimanches je les accueille
personnellement qu'on les convainc les
animaux je veux que je faisais quand
même une
tous les jours tout le temps parce qu'il
faudrait aussi du fonctionnement du
château mais c'est un travail au fond de
faire le lien sincère entre le breteuil
qui est là et puis les bretelles
d'autrefois alors quand je présente le
château j'ai voilà mon arrière grand
oncle en compagnie de louis saez etc
c'est plus vivant que de dire 'voilà
loué en guise de breteil en français on
peut en effet être liés
et puis en accueillant je trouve très
très sympathique et chaleureux et et je
dire à la limite normal de souhaiter la
bienvenue aux visiteurs qui nous aident
à sauver ce château parce que tous les
visites mise d'un petit mécènes en
quelque sorte grâce aux aides
vous avez tant en quelque sorte un des
pionniers pour l'ouverture du château et
la création d'événements pour attirer le
public 1 exactement je crois qu'un
château c'est un lieu de spectacle ya le
spectacle permanent
la visite du château la visite des
jardins les scènes de compte les
conteuses et puis à les animations
exceptionnelles qui vont donner au
visiteur envie de revenir et ce sont les
expositions les décorations de noël en
ce moment les journées particulières
tous les dimanches à la belle saison etc
c'est comme ça que le château peut
revivre et j'ai appelé mon livre un
château pour tous pour bien montrer que
breteil c'est château pour tout le monde
pour toutes les familles pour tous les
enfants
c'est cela dès la définition de breteuil
merci beaucoup je vous propose qu'on se
retrouve dans quelques temps pour parler
un petit peu de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui attendant pendant les fêtes
de noël merci beaucoup